it's early morning in the nakuru
national park in Kenya and a team of
gamekeepers and biologists has
tranquilized a rhinoceros they have 10
minutes until the animal wakes up again
in the meantime the Rhinos enormous body
has to be kept cooled with water they
take its measurements and a blood sample
and also remove a tiny piece of one year
we have a teaching loading have a louder
than usual help the hair samples when
you do but with a cup the samples are
sent to a laboratory in the capital
Nairobi their researchers analyzed the
animals DNA and record the results in a
special database or rhinos and elephants
so you get a variety of something like
avoid this kind of ivory data we cut
them from the base of the of the Han
this case usually handle Ivorian you can
see this is already process they have
been cut into chips we can see it's very
hard for you to know that this is I
worry when poachers are caught with a
piece of ivory or rhino horn the
researchers can then use the computer
records to determine which animal it was
taken from the team in Kenya cooperate
closely with their counterparts in South
Africa who first developed the database
yesterday we received seven homes here
from a guy was arrested yang Kang from
was a big so those samples you are going
to take to link get their profiles and
then link them with our database it's
the only way the team can prove that the
horn in question has been illegally
acquired but high demand and soaring
prices on the black market mean that
poaching continues to grow most of the
horns end up in Asia that's where
genetic engineer George bone AC and his
partner Matthew Marcus come in in their
laboratory in San Francisco on the west
coast of the u.s. their manufacturing
artificial rhino horn the aim is to
flood the market with their cut-price
version black market price right now
there's ranges from 30 thousand dollars
per kilogram to up to a hundred thousand
dollars per kilogram we're start
targeting seven thousand dollar per
kilogram figure and we think that that
is going to be a good price point that
will put a lot of pressure on the
poachers in the poaching syndicates
because it'll be harder for them to make
money to bribe officials and to do other
things the artificial horn largely
consists of rhino keratin made with
biotechnological methods the bio
engineers also a dry no DNA with the
help of 3d printer the resulting powder
is then transformed into a full-size
solid horn because of the manufacturing
process the result doesn't just look
like a rhino horn the researchers say
it's genetically identical they show us
a prototype we're going to be looking at
shark fin which is obviously very
popular in China Pangolin scales which
are also made of keratin tiger bone
which is also used in traditional
Chinese medicine ivory which obviously
has a lot of history in the West for use
and durable good products so all kinds
of anything that where an animal is used
in a tradition we want to be able to
remove that animal from the goods chain
opinion is divided on whether the
artificial horn will actually put
poachers out of business but with the
rhino population in Kenya now down to
just a thousand animals they need all
the help they can get